today on the matt walsh show a week
before the inauguration and democrat
mayors are rushing to reopen their
cities and restart their their economies
the timing
of this we're supposed to believe is
entirely coincidental sure also five
headlines including an interview with
jacob blake that
unwittingly destroys the narrative in
his defense and in our daily
cancellation we will discuss the major
controversy huge controversy surrounding
a traumatizing article in politico
written by ben shapiro that and much
more today on the matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
before we get into the show today i want
to tell you about one of our new
sponsors serve
hq you know the question always comes up
what can we do
as conservatives facing what we're
facing right now especially in the years
ahead what can we do
to to to make some headway in the
culture and one thing we can do is to
support
grassroots organizations that align with
our values
serve hq is a six-year-old company that
helps churches and non-profits train and
equip their volunteers to serve their
communities
they offer two online tools one for
training and one for communication
that thousands of churches and
nonprofits have already used
first our training tool lets you build
simple online courses for your
volunteers and staff
with video based training follow-up
quizzes and automated step-by-step
onboarding which is also included and
second their online communication tool
helps big and small teams with texting
email chat all in one place
it includes mobile apps for iphone and
android and it's designed to replace all
the different
communication tools you might use for
chat newsletters text blasts so
you're getting all this stuff in one
place it makes it so much easier
much more efficient uh their website
again is servehq
dot church that's serve hq dot church
serve hq is offering a new
special for the new year for any
organization that signs up during the
month of january
so you've got you know a few weeks left
to take to take advantage of this but i
would do it right now to make sure you
don't miss out
use code walsh to get 10 off for life
during this month only 10 off for life
during this month only churches and
nonprofits can train volunteers
teach core principles communicate with
teams and individuals and automate
recurring or multi-step tasks go to
servehq.church to learn more
and start your 14-day trial right now
use codewalls to get 10
off for life you know when i was a young
lad
one of my dad's most common refrains uh
to me and
my siblings whenever whenever we tried
to lie to him about something he would
always say
don't insult my intelligence and his
point was that you know it's bad enough
for us to do
whatever wrong thing we're trying to
cover up and it's even worse for us to
lie about it but then
the final indignity is to tell lies that
are so blatant and so
obvious that we are insulting our
parents intelligence by thinking they'd
be dumb enough to fall for the ruse in
the first place
now these days i can relate to how my
parents felt i can relate as a parent
myself like when my four-year-old
looked me in the eye and told me that he
didn't color in blue crayon on the wall
while literally holding the blue crayon
in his hand and standing right next to
the scribble on the wall
but i can also relate as a citizen of
this country because in this capacity
i we are lied to all the time especially
in recent months
and what makes the lies all the worse is
that it's it's
so obvious what they're doing and thus
insulting
they are insulting our intelligence for
example as we approach joe biden's
inauguration less than a week away
suddenly we're seeing democrat mayors
across the country
some of the biggest most ardent
proponents of lockdowns
now insist that we have to begin to open
up the economy again as quickly as
possible
so they've switched course like this as
blatantly as this with
with with timing as convenient as this
and they expect us to not notice
they insult our intelligence here's the
article in outkick about lori lightfoot
in chicago here's what she's saying
lori lightfoot the mayor of chicago on
thursday called for bars and restaurants
to be open at limited capacity
as soon as possible and said she would
speak to illinois governor jb
pritzker about the matter the second
round of shutdowns began in october
as cover 19 spread in the city and state
per block club chicago mayor lightfoot
said she is
very very focused on getting bars and
restaurants open
and pointed out that they can be
operated more safely for patrons than
than the underground parties that have
proliferated in the shutdown
if we have people and give them an
outlet for entertainment
we have much more of an opportunity in
my view to be able to regulate and
control that environment according to
lightfoot she said quote
let's bring it out of the shadows let's
allow them to have some recreation in
restaurants and bars
where we can actually work with
responsible owners and managers to
regulate and protect people from covet
19.
okay so we are not mass murderers
apparently or grandma killers if we want
to open up the economy is that what
we're saying
so that's that's allowed now we're
allowed to make that argument
without being shouted down and told that
we are
evil killers let me guess actually
let me guess i bet you now now we're
going to be mass murderers and grandma
killers
if we don't want to open the economy
because that's the way it works when the
pendulum swings
but again remember you aren't supposed
to notice this
governor cuomo's 180 is even more
egregious
here he is in his state of the state
address
singing a wildly different tune about
lockdowns listen
we must deal with a short-term economic
crisis
a record 15 billion dollar state deficit
that must be addressed in the next
several weeks
fourth we must plan our economic
resurgence
we simply cannot stay closed
until the vaccine hits critical mass the
cost is too high
we will have nothing left to open
we must reopen the economy but we must
do it smartly and safely
we simply cannot stay closed
we just can't what gets me is is not
just what he's saying
but how he's saying it he says we simply
cannot stay closed
with a level of exasperation that
seems to suggest that he's been saying
this for months and nobody would listen
but in fact of course we have been
saying that for months and he wouldn't
listen
so cuomo is really he's really like that
kid in the group project in school
who uh who you know you you have all the
good ideas and he keeps taking your
ideas and suggesting them
as if they're his own and in fact in
group projects in school i was actually
the guy taking the ideas
so he's like that but on a much larger
scale and with a lot more at stake he
doesn't even try to reconcile that
or explain his shift he pretends it's
not a shift he pretends that the last
nine months
never happened and he expects us to do
the same
we must do the same because as we've
learned to bring up the immediate recent
past to point out hypocrisy and double
standards
is to engage in what about ism and we
mustn't do that
no you can never say what about as we've
learned
you just have to pretend that that that
the whole universe was born this morning
and
there were no events that happened
before right now
that's what you have to pretend just let
them rewrite history right in front of
you let them do it
in fact implaud them applaud them as
they do it
that is your role in this that's what
you're expected to do
they have this set up so nicely and so
predictably you know biden will take
office the economy will open up again
at the same time it's going to get
warmer naturally right
um as we get into the spring and more
people will get vaccinated
and so the virus will recede and the
narrative will be that biden defeated
the virus and saved the economy
and did it all in his first three months
in office don't be surprised if he's
awarded the nobel prize for his efforts
and i'm not kidding
i really think that will happen i mean
they gave it to obama for doing
quite literally nothing what makes this
especially infuriating is again
we can all see them doing it because
they do it out in the open
and they do it exactly as we knew they
would meanwhile newsweek has just
published an article
uh with the headline coveted lockdowns
have no clear benefit
versus other voluntary measures
according to international study it
reads quote
a new study evaluating covet 19
responses around the world
found that mandatory lockdown orders
early in the pandemic
did not provide significantly more
benefits to slowing the spread of the
disease than
other voluntary measures such as social
distancing or travel reduction
it continues the study compared cases in
england france germany iran
italy netherlands spain and the u.s all
countries that implemented mandatory
lockdown orders and business closures
to south korea and sweden which
implemented less severe voluntary
responses it aimed to analyze the effect
that less restrictive or more
or more restrictive measures had on
changing individuals behaviors and
curbing the transmission of the virus
using that model the research has
determined that there is no clear
significant beneficial effect
of more restrictive measures on case
growth in any country
this is precisely what so many of us
have been saying for months
when you know it we weren't actually
arguing that we want more people to die
of the virus
we aren't super villains we're not
sociopaths quite the opposite
we argued that in our opinion the
lockdowns were not
a good way to deal with the virus there
were better ways to deal with it
and in our opinion more harm than good
is done by them in the long run
and it's not as though that argument was
simply rebuffed or refuted it's not as
though the other side said
well i disagree and here's why i'd have
no problem with that
that's fine let's have a discussion no
they said that to make such an argument
is evil in itself we are mass murderers
and lunatics for making it
and now the very people who said that to
us will start saying the same things
that we said before
but without acknowledgement without
accountability
and of course obviously without apology
so be it
you know this is the way the game is
played
and we would just do well to remember
that going forward
let's get now to our five headlines
before we get to five headlines a word
from zip recruiter listen it's a new
year
uh we got it got past a difficult year
to say the least especially for a lot of
businesses out there
and now is the perfect time to take your
business to the next level
by hiring the right people because
that's that's going to be one of the
first steps if you want to go to that
next level
um then you've got to have the right
people on board it's all about the
people
when you post a job on zip recruiter it
gets sent to over
100 top job sites with one click so it's
very easy for you then zip recruiters
matching technology
scans thousands of resumes and profiles
to send you the most qualified people
for your job
if you're really interested in a
candidate candidate you can uh invite
them to apply for your job
with one click so all this stuff on on
your end
this stuff is very very easy this is you
know this is the kind of task that would
have taken
hours and hours it cost you a lot of
money in the past but now you have zip
recruiter
zip recruiter sends them an email from
you and you stand out
from the competition because of that
it's so effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate
through the site within the first day
and think about that four to five
finance candidate within the first day
you can't you can't match that kind of
efficiency
or that sort of speed so this is what
you want to do right now you can try
ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.comwalls.ziprecruiter.com
w-a-l-s-h just go to
walsh ziprecruiter.com the smartest way
to hire
well i'm also happy to announce that
starting today january 15th andrew
clavin is back with a new weekly program
you thought he abandoned us for good but
he didn't he's back every friday
he'll be treated to a 90-minute show in
which andrew will wrap up the week's
events
talk to special guests give you his
unique insights into what's really going
on
and uh we'd love to hear especially what
he thinks about this week so make sure
you're subscribed to his show so you can
stay up to date on all new episodes all
right nfl playoffs
this weekend by the way i'm getting into
the divisional round i'm pretty excited
about that
baltimore ravens playing the buffalo
bills on saturday night
uh i think i think that'll be a great
game i like the ravens in the game
because i'm a homer number one but
number two because
um because of the run game you know the
buffalo bills really don't have a run
defense or a run offense
and uh the the ravens have both of those
things i mean they're averaging like 250
yards a game which is which is
insane they put up 400 yards a few weeks
ago which is unheard of like
teams used to do that in the 1950s uh on
the ground
so i'm i'm looking for that and let me
also just say
defensively here for a moment that uh
i i think i i mentioned football on the
show or maybe on on twitter
like one two or three times a year it
comes up
right of all the things that i'm
constantly blabbering about
maybe .001 percent of that is
football but any time i do there are two
there are two things that i hear from
people
um one is why are you talking about this
when there's so many other important
things happening in the world
what do you think you think football is
the most important thing happening
that you're talking about this and then
the other thing that i hear
is uh is well how could you watch
football how could you how could you
support the nfl
with with all their their political
shenanigans and everything they've done
how could you support them let me say in
response to both of those points
number one yeah there are a lot of bad
things happening in the world
i think it's still okay to
think about things that aren't
those bad things i think it's okay to
have other thoughts on occasion
it's even okay to engage in recreation
uh to have fun even i can have fun
sometimes
and if i can do it then what's wrong
with you but then the second point
you know the thing about well why would
you support the nfl
okay i can take that criticism i can't i
mean right they they they
the political stuff annoys me but i
certainly hope if you're making that
criticism of the nfl and saying oh well
you shouldn't watch the nfl
i really really hope that
you don't watch star wars or any other
disney movie
you don't watch anything on netflix or
hbo
you don't watch pretty much any movie or
any television show
that is ever produced except for run
hide fight which we premiered uh
last night which we'll talk more about
that a little a little bit later on
i certainly hope that's the case so i
think you're you're in a position to
make that criticism of people who watch
the nfl
if you do not watch any movies or any
television
at all period because if you do
and you support let's say a company like
disney
you support a company that does far more
damage in the culture
and and uh and spreads far more filth
and misleads far more people on a much
larger scale
than the nfl okay that's all um
but if you are in that category where
you say i don't watch
anything i don't even have a tv and uh
when i have recreational time i just
read books and i go
do gardening or something then i say to
you sir or ma'am i
i bow to you because i am very impressed
by that i just suspect that
you know 99 of the people who have that
criticism of the nfl
are not like you uh and that's my
problem okay
number one from the new york post joe
biden wants to uh to send millions of
americans their third stimulus check
and give others their first so as the
president-elect's 1.9
trillion economic relief plan calls for
yet another round of direct payments to
help people pay bills
and support their families during the
chronovirus pandemic the proposal would
also expand eligibility for the fourteen
hundred
dollar checks to some people left out of
the first two rounds of relief
one key group is adults who can be
claimed as dependents on other people's
income tax returns such as college
students or
elderly people being cared for by their
adult children
okay so adults like college students
so what we're being told now if you're
if you're an adult such as a college
student
and you're a dependent you're going to
get a
a covid relief check so you've got a 19
year old college student living at home
no bills to pay you we're going to send
them 1400 bucks
why for what reason
um both previous stimulus bills provided
providing direct payments only allowed
taxpayers to collect additional money
for dependent children younger than 17.
last march is
uh last march's cares act gave
households 500 for each qualifying kid
on top of 1200
per adult uh while december's 900
billion dollar uh relief package offered
600
checks for children and adults alike
okay well look
um as i've said all along i
i i'm in favor of the idea of providing
relief to people who've been who've been
so devastated uh financially by
the coveted lockdowns i think i think
the government has the responsibility to
do that
what i have a problem with is just
constantly
handing out checks to everyone without
any regard for whether they actually
need it or not so call me crazy but i i
sort of feel like if we're going to
spend
billions of dollars handing out checks
maybe we should take the time
put the energy and effort into and then
when i say we i mean the government
they're the ones that are going to have
to do this
uh into figuring out who actually needs
it
and then you know what you can send them
not only a check you can send them a
larger check
i'd be in favor of five thousand dollar
checks if they're actually going to the
people who really need it
say people who've lost their job because
of the lockdowns
business was shut down because of the
lockdowns there are they're teetering on
the edge of financial ruin or they're
or they're already in financial ruin um
yeah send them relief but
you know i happen to know and i'm sure
you know people too or maybe you are
someone like this
i know plenty of people who've been
getting these checks
and don't need it they don't need the
assistance they've been gainfully
employed the entire time if you have
been gainfully employed
throughout the chronovirus pandemic and
all the lockdowns
as i have been then you and i and
those of us in that category we are
blessed we're very fortunate
we don't need the checks we're in the
same position financially we were in
before we still have a job there's no
reason to send us money
um so that's my problem we are basically
the strategy is to throw money into the
air
and then hope it lands on some of the
people who really need it
and if we waste billions upon billions
giving it to people who don't need it
no problem well it is a problem
i would say number two we know that if
you're a conservative
guys like don lemon on cnn hate you
right no surprise there and that's why i
almost decided not to play this clip in
fact i i saw this clip circulating and
people talking about it
and i didn't even watch it at first
because i thought well yeah
well i get it by now it's like we talked
about yesterday that the hidden
camera footage of somebody works for pbs
talking about how much they hate
conservatives and
people some conservatives making a big
deal about that my reaction is well of
course i know they feel that way i don't
like it but i already know that there's
nothing about it that i consider
newsworthy
um but on the other hand this
from don lemon is so over the top
egregious
um and said publicly on the airwaves
that i think maybe it's worth taking a
second to reflect on it so here it is
listen if you are on that side
you need to think about the side you're
on i'm never on the side
of the clan i am not principal people
conservative or liberal
never on the clan side principal people
conservative or liberal
never on the nazi side principal people
who are conservative
or liberal never on the side
that treats their their fellow americans
as less than
that says that your fellow americans
should not exist
that said you're that says your fellow
americans should be in a concentration
camp
or that sides with slavery
what i like about that i guess is um
the incredible irony of uh he he says
well
you shouldn't treat your fellow
americans like they're less than
and he says that right after uh
claiming that trump supporters and
conservatives are on the side of the
clan
and nazis and slave owners
what no that's
that's what it means that's what it
looks like to treat people like they are
less than
like they are less than you you
obviously believe that they are
less than you morally and we could
presume you believe they're less than
you
intellectually that's what it looks like
yes that's what it means to treat people
as they are as if they are
inferior when you compare people to
nazis and clan members and slave owners
you are treating them as they as if they
are inferior
not unless they really are clan members
in which case fine
but there are like i don't know seven
clan members in america
so if you want to take up time on your
airwaves condemning those seven people
then go ahead and do it
but to even say
like the vast majority of conservatives
aren't in the clan to even say
something like that is to play the game
this doesn't even need to be said
um it's to even say it is to play the
game that that don lemon once
wants you to play all right number three
from the daily wire
it says a mother of a four-year-old
child who refuses to disclose
whether the child is a biological boy or
girl and claims she let the child decide
their own gender
has stated that she's been accused of
child abuse
the mother kyle myers phd
of course a native of utah who moved to
australia wrote in
on the website mamma mia i've received
hundreds of messages and comments on
instagram and emails from people i don't
know
telling me my child should be taken away
from me my partner brent
and i do something called gender
creative parenting
for us this means we didn't assign a
binary girl or boy gender to our child
the child's name is zoomer by the way
zoomer so we've got
kyle brent and zoomer in the family
together
we don't disclose zoomer's genitals to
people who don't need to know
we use the gender neutral pronouns they
them there for zoomer
until they can tell us what pronouns and
labels fit best and zoomer tells about
learns about and explores gender without
stereotypical expectations or
restrictions
brent and i are just two among thousands
of people doing gender creative
parenting
uh all over the world yeah that's
uh
those people are correct that is child
abuse
that's that's that's what child abuse is
um so they they are exactly correct
and i love it when these parents it and
also because they they take this
attitude of well you know mind your own
business
what concern is it of yours what why are
all these people
uh messaging me messaging me with with
their opinions of my parenting
well it's because you wrote an article
about it and you published it for the
whole world to see
you you announced what you said was hey
world look at how i'm parenting
look at how i'm parenting everyone look
at my child zoomer
please please see everyone i want you to
see it
and then some people say oh i see it and
i think it's horrible
and your response is how dare you how
dare you give
intrude in our private lives
you know if you don't want your child to
be stereotyped or
to have expectations imposed on them
why are you publicizing this why are you
putting it out there for everybody
no the reason why it's abuse one of the
reasons
um is that it
it it is real when i call it abuse i
don't just mean
like it's low-level abuse or something
like that
um no no this is this is really
serious abuse because it it goes to a
level
you know that is that is that is really
deep and that it in that it
it deprives the child of an identity
that's what you're doing
so this is psychological abuse
um on the deepest possible level when
you're depriving your child of
his or her identity i have to say his or
her because i don't because i don't know
you
you know you're you're withholding that
information and it's one thing if you
want to withhold that information from
the public
okay fine the problem is you're
withholding the information
from your child too because the reality
is
your child little zoomer is a boy or a
girl
he is he or she is one of those things
and your child has a right to know which
one
just like you did growing up your child
has a right to know
who he is one way or another
and you're depriving him of that
and by the way i say i say him in the
general because that actually is proper
grammar to use the word him
in a general sense you're depriving your
child of that
it's hard for me to think of a worse
form of psychological abuse
than that
it's just a basic fact it's it's a basic
fact of of his life and his existence
who he is and you won't tell him
forcing him to live as this amorphous
ambiguous being
that's a choice he didn't make
if he wants to make that choice later on
and do this gender fluid gender creative
stunt
later on in life he can make that choice
like you have done
but no you are imposing that on him
you're forcing him
to do it all right number four
jacob blake um case that we have
followed
extensively on this show of course
he was the the uh the wanted felon
violent criminal shot by police
in kenosha wisconsin uh one of the cases
that led to
all the writing and everything that we
saw now we we haven't heard
really anything from him directly until
yesterday good morning america
had an interview with jacob blake and uh
they um
the thing is it's not as bad as i
expected it to be
but it's still utterly disgraceful okay
the interview
could have been even worse than it was
and how it
you know portray in portraying jacob
blake as the victim
and it still does um it's not doesn't go
quite as far as i as i
as it could have gone but it's still
pretty bad
and meanwhile um jacob blake while he's
obviously
lying through his teeth he does
incriminate himself
and he also refutes unwittingly what his
own family had said
his family from the beginning had
claimed that he did not have a weapon
that he was unarmed
well he actually admits that he did have
a weapon that he was armed he tries to
he tries to dress it up in in such a way
as to make himself innocent
uh and he does it in a really absurd way
so we'll take a
we'll watch that now let's let's listen
we see you when you walk away from the
officers
after they try to grab you i'm rattled
you know i realized i had dropped my
knife
and a little pocket knife so i picked it
up
after i got off of him because they
tased me
and i fell on top of him with an open
knife at hand
that blake says fell out of his pocket
he walks around the front of the vehicle
towards the driver's side door
now okay so his claim about the knife if
you
picked up on it there uh he says that
well
it was just in his pocket and it
happened to fall out
and it and it was open when it fell so
he had so he had an open pocket knife in
his pocket can i just tell you
that's not a good place to have an open
pocket knife that's you're asking for
trouble
um having an open pocket knife in your
pocket there are a lot of things
a lot of things that can happen in in in
that situation that you don't want to
have happened um
have happened so he claims that he had
an open pocket knife in his pocket it
fell out he picked it up didn't close it
he had
he was holding the open pocket knife and
then he claims that it wasn't in the
clip there but he's as he continues
um he says that he he was all he was
trying to do
was take the open knife to his car
and just put it store it safely in his
car and then he would give himself up
and surrender that's all he was trying
that's why he was going to the car
that's why he was going to the car
with an open pocket knife while the cops
were screaming at him and telling him to
stop
was just so he could safely stow his
pocket knife you know jacob blake
accused rapist he's he's a good citizen
and he was just really concerned about
leaving the pocket knife on the ground
and a child might find it and
so you know while police were pointing
guns at him and screaming at him to stop
he he just thought he just thought well
let me just put this pocket knife away
he never said that by the way he never
said oh can i just uh please could i
just put my pocket knife away i'm
worried about someone
getting cut good he never said that of
course if he had said that they would
have told him
don't worry about it we'll take care of
the knife that's evidence we're taking
that with us
that's his claim and of course there's
no push back on that
at all uh michael strahan there former
nfl
guy that's the guy they bring in for
this hard-hitting interview
he doesn't there's no push back on that
um also at no point
is jacob blake asked about the alleged
rape
you know his his ex-girlfriend mother of
his children
accuses him very credibly of breaking
into his house
of into her house and raping her
and then stealing her credit cards and
her car he was trying to steal her car
again there
that's why she called police he's never
asked about that
you know we've also we also have not
heard from the woman at all this entire
time
no no one has inquired after her see how
she's doing or how she feels about any
of this
so never ask about that the only reason
i say it wasn't quite as bad as expected
is that um they do at least mention
that he had a warrant out for his arrest
and later on in the interview it's like
a seven minute interview michael strahan
does ask him you know well why did you
keep walking away from the cops
probably the smart thing to do would be
to just stop and and give yourself up at
that point
so they do say that at least that's how
low the standards are now
that at least that point
that it wasn't as bad as it could have
been but it was still really really bad
especially because of the way that they
are just erasing
and ignoring the real victim in this
whole thing which is the woman
she was the one who called police and
she continues to be victimized
every every day she has to turn on tv
and see this guy
see the way they make a martyr of him
she continues to be victimized
and she has to live now you know with
with people blaming her
for calling the police in the first
place
jake blake also claimed that uh
he he didn't know like
the reason why he was resisting arrest
at first and fighting the cops is
because he didn't know they were the
cops
that they grabbed him and he just didn't
know who it was
and uh and so he started fighting
without seeing anything i guess he had
his eyes closed and he was just flailing
and then he said that the reason he kept
walking away and didn't listen to the
officers
is because he didn't hear them because
his ears were ringing it was muffled
his ears were ringing because of all the
screaming and he just couldn't hear
anything so he couldn't see anything he
couldn't hear anything
he picked up the open knife just to put
in his car
do you wonder why police officers are
sometimes short on patients
is because they have to deal with this
bs every single day
just people lying blatantly to their
face making up the most absurd excuses
for illegal behavior this is what police
officers deal with every single day
all right number five this is one of
those stories that's almost like
it's almost like hearing someone
describe getting a paper cut
and that you just you just feel it you
feel this story
only this is a lot worse than a paper
cut from entrepreneur.com it says stefan
thomas a german programmer based in san
francisco
forgot a password that would allow him
to access 7000
bitcoin which could be worth 220 million
dollars
according to new york times the password
will allow thomas to unlock a small hard
drive
called the iron key which holds the keys
to a digital wallet containing 7000
bitcoin
thomas lost the document where he wrote
the key to his iron key years ago
and he only has two attempts left to
gain access
so i guess i don't know how many
attempts he's made so far but there are
only so many attempts before they lock
you up permanently
and he's been trying to guess these
passwords he's got 220 million dollars
theoretically um he's got a theoretical
220 million dollars
behind that iron key and he can't get in
and uh if he if he
guesses wrong two times then the device
will encrypt your content forever the
programmer obtained this amount of
cryptocurrency in 2011 we lived in
switzerland
after making an animated video
explaining what his bitcoin
uh requested by a fan of the asset
thomas is not the only one who has lost
his money this way according to the new
york times article
citing chain analysis of the existing
18.5 million bitcoin around 20
around 20 currently worth around 140
billion dollars
seem to be lost or stranded in wallets
that's pretty bad uh and it just it
makes me feel better about not getting
involved with bitcoin because
you know i'm terrible with passwords
basically there are two strategies that
i've found
with strat with with passwords one is
that you have
one password that's very memorable and
you use it for all of your accounts
and the problem is that if any genius
hacker ever thinks to guess
like password password123 or something
they'll be able to bankrupt you
and steal your identity in four and a
half minutes because they can access
everything
and the other strategy is to use a this
is what i do i use a difficult and
unique password for everything
but then i forget it immediately and so
anytime i want to access
anything that has an account i have to
always go to
uh forgot password do the whole thing
it's so bad that i'll i'll
i'll set up an account somewhere i'll
set my password
and then i'll go to login to the account
i just set up and i've already forgotten
it and i have to go and do
remember remember password so that's
that's the problem
i also have to admit that um
for this reason and others i i don't
really see
the value uh with with bitcoin
admittedly i know almost nothing about
it
so if you're a bitcoin expert i'm sure
you'll have a chance
to post your actually comments uh below
so so you're welcome for that you can
you can school me in it but
it seems to me this is what as someone
who's totally this is just my
my intuitive analysis as someone who
knows almost nothing about
cryptocurrency
it seems to me that for a currency to
really be a currency
it needs to be used like one right so
you have to use it to buy goods and
services
if you're not using it to buy goods and
services if it isn't commonly used for
that it's not really a currency
but bitcoins bitcoin is a zillion
dollars so
and there aren't very many of them and
they're hard to obtain
and they can be hard to access once you
have them so people don't use them as
currency
and they just buy and sell bitcoin with
other fans of bitcoin
so that seems to me to not really be a
currency but more of a collectible
my expert analysis is that bitcoin is
just a glorified form
of a beanie baby or pokemon card
that's all it really is it's just a
high-tech really expensive
pokemon card there you go
take that to the bank that's my
financial advice well i'm not a business
owner myself but
one thing i've i hear from business
owners that i talk to is uh
the the thing that can that can kill you
especially early on
if you're a small business is hr issues
all the red tape
everything you have to wade through um
and you're not you're not
just because you want to start a
business you're an entrepreneur you're
not necessarily going to be expert
in those areas and you can't be an
expert in every area right wrongful
termination
suits minimum wage requirements labor
regulations you got to deal with all of
that
and hr managers salaries are not cheap
we're talking about an average of 70
000 a year on top of all the the
difficulties you have to deal with
that's why you need bambi spelled
b-a-n-b-e-e
was created specifically for small
businesses small business owners like
yourself you can get a dedicated hr
manager you can craft hr policy and
maintain your compliance all for just 99
a month so you can spend 75 000 a year
or 99 bucks a month i'm not great at
math but i think
the math works out in your favor with
bambi i'm pretty sure with bambi you can
change
hr from your biggest liability to your
biggest strength from onboarding
determinations they customize your
policies to fit your business
and they help you manage your employees
day to day all for just 99
a month month to month no hidden fees
cancel any time like you didn't start
your business because you want to spend
time on hr compliance rarely do i hear
business owners say that the reason they
got into business
was because of their passion for hr
compliance
every once while someone says that those
are the weirdest but probably not the
case for you so get
bambi go to bambi.com walsh right now to
schedule your free hr audit
that's bambi.com walsh spelled
b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com slash walsh and last night
uh was a big big night as referenced
earlier for the daily wire we made our
entrance into entertainment content with
our first feature film run hide fight
uh if you missed it head on over to
dailywire.com or you can watch it right
now
and uh if you want to know if it's good
or not let me
i can tell you it uh it's it's a very
good movie and you can listen to me and
you should just listen to me
in all things i hope you know that by
now but uh if you don't believe me just
go go online go to social media look at
some of the comments
um the uh the people have spoken and the
reception to this movie has been
absolutely it's really it's blown me
away especially because it's
you know you figure even if it's good
even if i know it's good
people especially on the internet will
find reasons to hate it
and there's been very little of that
that should really tell you something
now please be aware this film is not
political it is intense it's for mature
audiences only starring isabelle may
thomas jane and
rod have mitchell run hide fight follows
zoe hall who's a high school student
coping with the recent loss of her
mother all she wants to do is get
through the last few weeks of her senior
year leave for college with a fresh
start
but instead her high school was attacked
by four gun-toting students
who plan their siege and start to start
to take over the school
and using her wits and survival skills
zoe fights back to save her fellow
students
we're excited to bring you great stories
that hollywood refuses to tell
we hope you'll join us be a part of the
of the adventure become a member today
over at dailywire.com
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we are
going to briefly discuss the dire
controversy surrounding ben shapiro's
article in politico
if you don't spend a lot of time on
social media then
your life is a whole lot more fulfilling
and meaningful than those of us who do
but the downside is you miss
important news like this it was trending
all over twitter yesterday people were
very upset that ben shapiro wrote an
article for politico's newsletter called
the playbook
and ben's piece was mostly about
impeachment and trying to explain
you know why many republicans oppose it
from his point of view and his
his argument comes down to this
paragraph where he says quote opposition
to impeachment comes from a deep and
abiding conservative belief that members
of the opposing political tribe want
their destruction
not simply to punish trump for his
behavior republicans believe that
democrats in the overwhelmingly liberal
media
see impeachment as an attempt to cudgel
them collectively by lumping them in
with capital rioters thanks to their
support of trump okay
now you might think well okay that seems
reasonable
certainly not in any way offensive or
traumatizing or radical
but many in media and many employees at
politico didn't agree
they claimed that politico had acted in
a deeply irresponsible fashion by
allowing ben shapiro to write a
newsletter
they pointed out that ben shapiro an
orthodox jew is also a white supremacist
nazi
a white supremacist nazi orthodox jew i
mean those exist
i'm told there's at least one of them
they pointed out that he has opinions um
many opinions some of which
they the members of the media don't
agree with
and it's simply not acceptable for a
person with those sorts of opinions to
be allowed in politico
or frankly anywhere else on earth eric
wempel media critic for the washington
post was tweeting updates on the
controversy throughout the day
there was apparently a revolt among
political staffers
who felt that they all personally should
have been consulted before their boss
made the decision to let ben shapiro
write a guest column for them
wempel tweeted there are now upwards of
225 people on the politico zoom call
convened to hash out the decision to
invite ben shapiro to guest write an
edition of playbook people are very mad
i am hearing
very very mad this is the kind of thing
you hear about a lot these days
underlings at companies getting their
feelings hurt by decisions that don't
personally affect them in any way
whatsoever
then they cry about it publicly and
management for some reason
takes their temper tantrum seriously and
gives them a forum to vent their
childish rage in fairness you might
point out that
my company has given me a forum to vent
my childish rage also and it's the very
show you're listening to right now but
that's beside the point
this isn't about me this is about ben
shapiro and he is the one canceled today
now pl please don't think that i would
cancel all the people
who've broken down in tears over a
completely inoffensive and utterly
reasonable article in politico
written by a conservative no i i
understand their feelings i
also wept uncontrollably when i first
read it
i could not stand to see the sacred
hallowed ground of the political
playbook
so desecrated the political playbook is
is deeply important to many people you
see myself included
i have been a huge lifelong fan of the
political playbook
ever since i first heard about it
yesterday afternoon
and at any rate ben should know that
when you're a conservative
you have no right to make your arguments
or express your beliefs in
any mainstream forum you shouldn't even
be
seen in public without prior warning
i've always i've always said this that
conservatives ought to wear cowbells
around their necks
when they leave their homes so that
strangers will be warned of their
imminent arrival
into a room see it's bad enough to
simply be seen
you know to force others to endure
the spectacle of your existence
as a conservative merely merely by your
presence in a room you run the risk of
causing
fatal emotional wounds to everybody in
vicinity but to actually speak
to express your beliefs and ideas to
make arguments
well that's tantamount to terrorism mass
murder this is a true this is an
absolutely true story okay i promise you
i was at a thanksgiving dinner once a
few years ago um
one of the people at the table was a
conservative and he was explaining you
know why he believes in gun rights he's
making his arguments and i'm not
exaggerating when i tell you that
four people in the dining room dropped
dead on the spot
i mean they just they disagreed so
strongly with the arguments that their
hearts gave out
and they perished it was a bloodbath so
this is what's at stake
ben by writing an article for politico
has shown a reckless disregard for the
feelings and therefore the lives of so
many americans
and that's why i moved not only to
cancel ben shapiro but also to impeach
him
i will be drawing up articles of
impeachment this afternoon he is charged
with
incitement treason and other acts of
general and unspecified meanness may god
have mercy on his soul
and may god comfort the staff at
politico in this trying time
that's going to do it for us today
thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening have a great
weekend godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledovsky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show the media
swivel and attack republicans across the
board not just the capital rioters
all republicans plus politico staff go
wild after i write the morning playbook
that sacred
morning playbook give it a listen that's
today on the bench bureau show